What's the most important century
in human history?
Some might argue it’s a period
of extensive military campaigning,
like Alexander the Great’s
in the 300s BCE,
which reshaped political
and cultural borders.
Others might cite the emergence
of a major religion,
such as Islam in the 7th century,
which codified and spread values
across such borders.
Or perhaps it’s the Industrial Revolution
of the 1700s
that transformed global commerce
and redefined humanity's relationship
with labor.
Whatever the answer, it seems like
any century vying for that top spot
is at a moment of great change—
when the actions of our ancestors shifted
humanity’s trajectory
for centuries to come.
So if this is our metric,
is it possible that right now—
this century—
is the most important one yet?
The 21st century has already proven to be
a period of rapid technological growth.
Phones and computers have accelerated
the pace of life.
And we’re likely on the cusp of developing
new transformative technologies,
like advanced artificial intelligence,
that could entirely change
the way people live.
Meanwhile, many technologies
we already have
contribute to humanity’s unprecedented
levels of existential risk—
that’s the risk of our
species going extinct
or experiencing some kind of disaster
that permanently limits
humanity’s ability to grow and thrive.
The invention of the atomic bomb marked
a major rise in existential risk,
and since then we’ve only increased
the odds against us.
It’s profoundly difficult
to estimate the odds
of an existential collapse
occurring this century.
Very rough guesses put the risk
of existential catastrophe
due to nuclear winter and climate change
at around 0.1%,
with the odds of a pandemic causing
the same kind of collapse
at a frightening 3%.
Given that any of these disasters could
mean the end of life as we know it,
these aren’t exactly small figures,
And it’s possible this century could see
the rise of new technologies
that introduce more existential risks.
AI experts have a wide range
of estimates regarding
when artificial general intelligence
will emerge,
but according to some surveys,
many believe it could happen this century.
Currently, we have relatively narrow forms
of artificial intelligence,
which are designed to do specific tasks
like play chess or recognize faces.
Even narrow AIs that do creative work are
limited to their singular specialty.
But artificial general intelligences,
or AGIs,
would be able to adapt to and
perform any number of tasks,
quickly outpacing
their human counterparts.
There are a huge variety of guesses
about what AGI could look like,
and what it would mean
for humanity to share the Earth
with another sentient entity.
AGIs might help us achieve our goals,
they might regard us as inconsequential,
or, they might see us as an obstacle
to swiftly remove.
So in terms of existential risk,
it's imperative the values of this new
technology align with our own.
This is an incredibly difficult
philosophical and engineering challenge
that will require a lot
of delicate, thoughtful work.
Yet, even if we succeed, AGI could still
lead to another complicated outcome.
Let’s imagine an AGI emerges
with deep respect for human life
and a desire to solve
all humanity’s troubles.
But to avoid becoming misaligned,
it's been developed to be incredibly
rigid about its beliefs.
If these machines became
the dominant power on Earth,
their strict values might
become hegemonic,
locking humanity into one ideology that
would be incredibly resistant to change.
History has taught us that
no matter how enlightened
a civilization thinks they are,
they are rarely up to the moral standards
of later generations.
And this kind of value lock in
could permanently distort or constrain
humanity’s moral growth.
There's a ton of uncertainty around AGI,
and it’s profoundly difficult to predict
how any existential risks
will play out over the next century.
It’s also possible that new,
more pressing concerns
might render these risks moot.
But even if we can't definitively say that
ours is the most important century,
it still seems like the decisions
we make might have a major impact
on humanity’s future.
So maybe we should all live
like the future depends on us—
because actually, it just might.